[Música]
aquí a mis espaldas es donde se realizó
la conferencia del agua de la ONU la
primera que hace Naciones Unidas en casi
50 años después de que la primera fue en
mar del plata Argentina Cuál fue el
objetivo lograr compromisos voluntarios
en la agenda de la acción por el agua y
más allá de eso era crear un momento un
político para poner los recursos
hídricos y también el saneamiento en el
centro del debate veamos qué fue lo que
ocurrió el agua potable y el saneamiento
son derechos humanos Y aunque los son
desde 2010 la conferencia de la ONU
revivió la discusión luego de tres días
de reuniones Naciones Unidas afirmó que
el agua Debería ser el centro del debate
pues es el eje transversal de la
seguridad alimentaria la salud la
energía y el clima Cuáles son las
soluciones
de hecho sí sabemos Cuáles son las
soluciones en términos de finanza
infraestructura gobernanza lo que no
estamos haciendo bien es conectar para
tener una visión integrada y sistémica
para el manejo del agua
para tener una visión transversal es que
los países promueven la creación de un
enviado especial de la ONU para el agua
una propuesta que el secretario general
Antonio Gutiérrez Se comprometió a
estudiar además en la agenda de acción
hubo más de 700 compromisos al respecto
ucha insiste en que las soluciones deben
ser basadas en la naturaleza
tenemos que acoger las soluciones
basadas en la naturaleza y la sabiduría
y el conocimiento de los pueblos
indígenas quienes han estado gobernando
y protegiendo los recursos hídricos por
mucho tiempo todavía estamos en el
modelo de la entrega centralizada del
agua y creo que entre más adoptemos
modelos descentralizados y centros de
acceso al agua mejor estaremos pero por
ahora el mundo está lejos de alcanzar el
objetivo de desarrollo sostenible número
6 pues no todos tienen recursos hídricos
Cómo es vivir sin agua o por lo menos
sin agua suficiente esa es una de las
realidades que enfrenta Zamora en el
Estado de Michoacán en México y para
hablar del tema nos acompaña Carlos Soto
El Alcalde Carlos bienvenido aquí a
France 24 y empecemos por hablar de cómo
es esa realidad y que tanta seguridad
hídrica tiene Zamora y si la escasez
está relacionada o no con la siembra de
aguacate bien bueno Pues primeramente un
saludo a todos y decirles que
lamentablemente en un valle tan rico en
tanta agricultura porque dependemos 100%
de la agricultura No contamos con la
cantidad de agua necesaria para los
cultivos precisamente agrícolas
recordemos que somos el primer lugar en
exportación de berries Aunque El
Aguacate como todo en el mundo y también
por estar tan cercano a nuestro Valle
repercute mucho en el tema del agua
Tendremos que trabajar Tenemos que
trabajar muy pero muy duro primero en el
saneamiento de todas estas aguas que
tenemos y además poder rescatar toda
esta agua que muchas veces se
desperdicia que en el valle no la
tenemos pero en nuestros alrededores por
ser Zamora cabecera municipal no puede
llegar a nosotros de la manera en que
queremos y frente a esa crisis que
enfrenta Zamora uno de los planes es
reutilizar las aguas
implica el reutilizar las aguas
precisamente sanear poder platicar y que
te haya una gobernanza del agua que no
existe que pueda haber una estructura
donde podamos tener financiamiento de
instituciones tan importantes como la
Organización de las Naciones Unidas que
es donde nos encontramos ahorita porque
había queja de algunos países escuchando
todas las ponencias que además fueron
muy enriquecedoras donde dice ya den
suerte en recurso gestionemos recursos
Aunque la ONU no es el que gestiona la
ONU es el puente para que llegue este
recurso pero involucrar al empresariado
involucrar a la ciudadanía con cultura
del agua donde tenemos que aprender a
cuidar este vital líquido y entonces sí
poder gestionar junto con estas todo
este tipo de organizaciones recurso para
los países para los municipios donde más
lo necesitan que no llegue al mismo
lugar donde ya se ha resuelto un poco
este problema y hay lugares donde
tenemos una y un problema fuerte en el
tema del agua recursos y gestión dos
temas claves no solo en la conferencia
de la ONU sino en todo lo relacionado
con los recursos
hídricos Especialmente cuando una misma
Fuente de Agua atraviesa los límites
nacionales en el mundo existen por lo
menos 280 Ríos transfronterizos pero dos
tercios de ellos no cuentan con ninguna
protección por eso en la conferencia
hubo un llamado reiterado a un tratado
en el tema y países como Egipto lo
catalogaron como una cuestión
existencial pero no solo es cooperación
también se trata de la distribución
equitativa un tema fundamental en el
agua y es que el 72% de todos los puntos
de los que se extrae agua en el mundo
son utilizados por la agricultura según
la ONU al respecto hablamos con Joe pury
la vicepresidenta del fondo
internacional de desarrollo agrícola
Esto fue lo que nos dijo
creo tenemos que empezar por entender
dónde en el espectro global de
agricultura gran y pequeña escala
necesitamos hacer el mayor esfuerzo
adicional
porque no es solo una cuestión de
eficiencia sino también de equidad
economía y bienestar
dado que un gran número de agricultores
en el mundo cultivan pequeños pedazos de
tierra
de menos de 5 o 12 hectáreas claramente
son una parte importante del espectro
global y los más necesitados
tenemos que pensar dónde estamos
construyendo esta perspectiva de
conexión entre agua seguridad
alimentaria y energía y lo tenemos que
hacer en un trabajo integral la razón
por la que la distribución equitativa
importa tanto es que las fuentes de agua
no existen en todo el planeta de hecho
las principales cuencas atraviesan unas
cuantas naciones
cinco de las más grandes del mundo son
las del río Nilo en África el Amazonas
en Sudamérica el llancé que recorre
parte de China el Mississippi en Estados
Unidos o el Jenny de Rusia sin contar el
río de la plata en el cono Sur pero ni
siquiera teniendo una de estas grandes
cuencas los países pueden garantizar su
acceso al agua de hecho dos de las cinco
cuencas más grandes del mundo están en
América Latina y sin embargo Ninguno de
los países de la región catalogó como
país seguro
hídricamente según el más reciente
reporte del instituto para agua ambiente
y salud que es el brazo académico de la
ONU Ellos sólo posicionaron en la región
a Estados Unidos y Canadá como países
seguros
hídricamente Joe pury nos explicó A qué
se debe este fenómeno
si miramos por ejemplo las diez cuencas
principales en un reporte reciente
afirmó que sobre ellas viven 1700
millones de personas pero la mayoría
viven en condición de alto estrés
hídrico
en Brasil a pesar de que haya buena
abundancia las partes del nordeste y
sudeste que son las más pobladas no son
las que tienen agua
Entonces esto realmente es una cuestión
de gobernanza y de inversión la idea de
estas políticas y del decenio de la
acción por el agua es que haya un acceso
universal a los recursos
hídricos y sin embargo actualmente un
cuarto de la población mundial no tiene
acceso a agua potable por eso aquí en
Nueva York más de 500 organizaciones se
unieron para firmar el manifiesto por la
Justicia del agua un documento que busca
que haya un proceso realmente universal
y también promueve que haya un mecanismo
dentro de la ONU dedicado únicamente a
velar este tema y los llamados son
urgentes porque como lo mostró la
síntesis del sexto reporte del ipcc de
aquí al 2030 los países deben recortar a
la mitad sus gases contaminantes sino la
crisis climática será todavía peor una
crisis que está profundamente ligada con
el agua actualmente tres de cada cuatro
desastres naturales están relacionados
con los recursos
hídricos y una de las consecuencias las
hemos visto en América Latina para
hablar de este tema me acompaña Miguel
Doria especialista de la UNESCO basado
en Montevideo y también el viceministro
de ambiente de Uruguay Gerardo amarilla
Bienvenidos a los dos y quiero comenzar
con usted Gerardo preguntándole cómo es
esa sequía que está atravesando Uruguay
y también países vecinos como chile y
Argentina bueno es la tercer sequía
consecutiva
en 46 años nunca hemos tenido nada igual
en todo el cono Sur eso está teniendo un
gran impacto en la producción
de alimentos que es nuestra principal
fuente de recursos como país allí hemos
calculado solamente en Uruguay el último
año dos mil millones de dólares de
pérdida además de las crisis sociales y
ambientales que genera esta falta de
agua
y le quiero preguntar a usted Mario Cuál
es el panorama en América Latina vemos
también estas sequías tanto en la parte
sur y también las inundaciones que han
golpeado Ecuador Perú y el calentamiento
global que está derritiendo los páramos
Cuál es un poco el panorama de la región
pues es una preocupación hace varias
décadas porque la relación entre agua y
clima es muy estrecha y ya mencionó la
par sequía que realmente afecta de una
forma severa varios paisajes son las
inundaciones también pero el deseo de
glaciares que donde la las poblaciones
andinas son dependientes y también los
ecosistemas de esa parte no y Los
Huracanes por ejemplo del que afecta el
Caribe y otras zonas costeras activo
impacto muy fuerte movimiento la vida de
las personas en el medio ambiente pero
también en lo que respecta los recursos
hídricos no de ahí que el Día Mundial
del agua de este año sea se va a cerrar
el cambio a hacer el cambio a nivel de
nuestra sociedades para una respuesta
adecua desafíos pero también para lograr
los grandes objetivos la agenda 2030 en
particular en los objetivos es que es
brindar agua y saneamiento a todos y
todas en acción y a nivel del mundo
acelerar el cambio no solo por la salud
de los humanos sino también de las
especies Y es que la biodiversidad
también está estrechamente relacionada
con el agua al respecto hablamos con
David Cooper el secretario ejecutivo del
convenio de diversidad biológica
creo que primero debemos enfocarnos en
los ecosistemas más vulnerables en las
áreas costeras Estos son arrecifes de
coral manglares y Pradera marina además
son muy importantes para las comunidades
locales muchos de esos sistemas albergan
una parte importante de la pesca y
ofrecen protección de las costas
controlando las otras presiones que
existen sobre ellos como reduciendo los
excesos de nutrientes que vienen de la
tierra de la agricultura de los
desperdicios humanos la sedimentación
limitándola sobre pesca o la pesca
destructiva podría darle a estos
ecosistemas una posibilidad de
sobrevivir al cambio climático pero
también necesitamos esforzarnos por
mantener uno coma cinco grados Celsius
para que tengan una oportunidad de
supervivencia
en altamar o las áreas más allá de la
jurisdicción nacional también hay
sistemas muy únicos en las profundidades
como los respiraderos hidrotermales a lo
largo de las regiones del océano son
áreas críticas altas en biodiversidad la
mayoría sin descubrir pero a la vez muy
vulnerables
así llegamos al final de nuestro
programa Recuerden que pueden ver este y
todos los episodios en France 24.com